david peterson two iffy starts one
real good start drafted by the red
stocks originally
in 2014 and then picked by the mets
coming out of oregon in the first round
two young umpires on this crew including
walcott behind the plate and the
fastball keeps hernandez looking
and so david peterson makes quick work
of [ __ ] hernandez for the first down of
the night
and everest grounds one weekly into the
shift hurrying in his mcneil to get it
in two quick outs
for david peterson first pitch to the
right hand better hit hard on the ground
to short but right at lindor he's got it
throws to first and plenty of time side
retired another sinker from peterson
that's the out pitch for him in this
first inning as he gets the red sox in
order
yeah it's all about garrett richards
tonight he's got to find a way
with his delivery to be able to repeat
it you know the stuff is there but you
got to be able to command
lindeur's seen him before he's just one
for eight with five strikeouts against
garrett
and a tapper charging and flipping on to
get the alexander bogarts
that's one twice here at fenway the red
sox went twice at city field the pitch
swinging a breaking ball lying in the
right field but coming out to stab it
renfro for the out there in the process
of getting back starters carlos carrasco
and noah cindergard did he offer yes he
did and he put him away
boy did garrett richards need that he
gets it one two three
deep intellect payoff pitch bounce to
the right side and to get it mcneil to
the right of second base throws the
first in time
one away and that's three straight
ground ball outs two-two pitch swung on
him miss strike three
peterson working that sinker again goes
away with it
balls right down the middle threw it by
him yeah after the change-ups and slow
stuff
surprised him with that fastball
and outside to put a man on so a walk of
renfrow
gonzalez hits one on the ground right
from mcneil so peterson continues to get
the grounders four of them in the first
two innings
oh and two of the count here's the pitch
swinging to miss it a curve he got him
off three pitches
this looks like a different guy lou
already richard rocks
kicks and fires and a check swing did he
go
he did says the first base umpire jerry
lane
on a slider away so there's his third
strikeout
so richards has retired the first five
and struck out the last three
and a jeff mcneil unloads to right field
forget that
jeff mcneal gets the next the lead into
the coca-cola corner
his second home run of the year and it's
one nothing new york a little cutter
didn't get it in enough
jeff all over it well that was just a
good old-fashioned jeff mcneill
first pitch fastball ambush and he drove
it way back to right field
still with that donut beside the home
run column boy he is
due to hit a bomb he just is
swaying a high fly ball into center
driving back pilar all the way to the
wall
leaping he can't get it and there's
number one there you go
bobby dulbeck for the first time this
season and he has tied the game at one
here at citi field yeah opposite field
but he has that kind of strength and we
saw that in spring training
over and over again
vasquez swings over the slider and
strikes out
for the second time gets the ground ball
to jd
out at second mcneil with a turn entire
double play
side retired richards with four
strikeouts so far
and the solo home run allowed swinging
to miss add another one foul tip to the
mitt and held by vasquez one gone
richards comes home and alonso takes a
curveball for strike three beautiful
hook
and they're two away boy this is crazy
that's drilled to left and that's down
for a basic and four to third will have
to be held there the ball was hit so
hard jd
martinez gets it in quickly and the mets
have first and third from mcneil
[Applause]
trying to go up top swinging a miss he
put him away
he struck him out two stranded
and the old one busted back
and a hit down the line martinez giving
chase
he's heading for second here's the throw
the tag and he's out
they cut him down all right he got a
little greedy
and martinez came up gunning
dropped in there for strike three he
fans the pitcher that strikeout number
eight for garrett richards
hammered the other way line shot down to
the corner that'll be a fair ball up
against that 330 mark
tk will dive on into second base he's
got himself a double
rafael he's got one for two of the
single
and he'll swing and lock that one into
left field that's going to drop down for
a hit
here comes the run hernandez
read that one beautifully he is in the
score it's an rbi for debras
and the red sox lead it 2-1 68 pitches
hasn't walked to seoul
that's a season high with the eight
strikeouts in fact it's twice as many as
any other start this year
richards throws swinging a miss he
struck him out great slider and alonso
is gone
that is the ninth strikeout swaying in a
high fly in the left field but toward
martinez jd's got room he lines it up
jd makes the play and the inning is over
garrett richards six outstanding innings
the lions went the right to lend or
diving to the back
beautifully done to keep it a one-run
game how about this garrett richards is
going back out there for another running
1-1
hard ground ball gobbled up by gonzalez
one away fastball
oh nice scoop by dalbeck he'll flip to
richards two down
bobby d how about the spin on that ball
the pitch
swing and a mess he struck him out
there's your one more pitch
inning over garrett richards has struck
out 10
and he throws seven brilliant innings
he did that's strike three that's good
morning good afternoon good night
swinging a high pop up
backing up devers and puts that away
two down in the night trying to end it
here on davis the one two
swinging a missing a breaking ball
vasquez will scoop it up throw on to
first
that's a strikeout the ball game is over
the red sox beat the mets 2-1
in what might turn out to be one of the
most important victories of the season